现在让我们连线嘉宾 CZ，
币安创始人。  CZ，非常感谢您
做客Galaxy Brands。 我想让
[音乐]问问关于Hyperlid的事。
所以，
我之前并不了解 Hyperlid 的一些有趣历史。
我们强制所有人使用比特币。 那
本身实际上并不是去中心化。
那是专制主义。
无论加密货币造成什么影响，它都
没有能力毁灭我们的
文明。 但人工智能拥有
熄灭音乐的力量。
你是否担心量子计算会对
比特币构成威胁？
不，我其实一点也不担心
。 我的意思是，加密货币不会消失。
加密货币将会成为一个庞大的产业。
好的。 是啊，我们可以
通过扼杀这个行业来规范它，
对吧？
嗯，那不是监管。 这简直就是
杀人。
欢迎来到银河大脑。
无穷无尽的现金。 我是
主持人亚历克斯。 美国银行体系
稳健且富有韧性。 比特币创下
历史新高。
如果你不够长，如果你不够长，
你就太短了。
Satashi会上来，
歇斯底里地大笑，然后安静下来。 哦，比特币
要被抹杀了。 比特币。 比特币是
有史以来最好的加密货币。 比特币即将
归零。
欢迎回到银河大脑。 和
往常一样，我是主持人 Alex Thorne，
Galaxy 公司全公司研究主管。
比特币的价值并非为零。
本周我们为您准备了一期精彩的节目。 币
安创始人赵长鹏是我们的嘉宾。 他来到
纽约的演播室，和我一起
探讨他在
加密货币领域丰富的经验，话题涵盖广泛。 他
对当前的市场周期有何看法？
回撤幅度是多少？ 会
持续多久？ 比特币是否已经触底？ 以及
其他一系列引人入胜的话题。 我们将
了解赵长鹏对人工智能的看法，他
目前个人在哪个
领域投资了什么，
传统金融和加密货币之间伟大融合的未来
会是什么样，以及更多内容。  BIM Net 本周暂停播出
，在我们开始对 CZ 的采访之前
，我需要提醒大家，请
参阅播客笔记中的免责声明链接
。 请注意，
本播客中的任何信息均不构成
投资建议，也不构成
Galaxy 或其任何关联公司
买卖任何证券的要约、推荐或招揽。 让我们
和 CZ 一起深入了解一下。 现在让我们连线我们的嘉宾，
币安创始人赵长鹏 (CZ)。  CZ，
非常感谢您做客Galaxy Brands。
谢谢你邀请我，亚历克斯。
嗯，谢谢您莅临我们
在纽约的办公室。 嗯，我想
先问问你关于当前
市场周期的问题。 嗯，我算了一下，结果
发现它确实是
四年周期，几乎精确到天。   是的
。   真是太
疯狂了。
嗯，你知道，我们离目标还很远，
离
历史最高纪录 12.5 万左右还很远。 嗯，这是
正常的生理周期吗？ 你觉得它会
看起来不一样吗？ 您认为
我们目前处于比特币
价格浪潮的哪个阶段？
所以，是的，我认为四年周期
实际上相当准确。 嗯，所以，嗯，我
认为这是一个非常正常的周期。 嗯，
你知道，你退回了大约 50%。 嗯，我
觉得我们见过更糟糕的情况。 我们
在之前的周期中已经看到过大约 80% 的回调
。   是的
。 如果你看看
四年前的低点，我
今天早些时候刚和别人聊过，大概是2022年这个时候，当时
可能是美国
股市暴跌，但并
没有触底。
后来在11月，FTX股市暴跌才
触底，当时股价大概是16000美元。
所以，我们现在的价格仍然比当时高出四五倍。是的，
所以如果你比较一下这两个低点，
四年内仍然上涨了五倍。
所以，我认为这是
一个正常的周期，但每个周期都会更高，
所以从长远来看…… 不，我是
长期伴侣。 我不会退出。
对我来说，加密货币领域没有出路[笑]
。 所以，嗯，是的。 所以，我
觉得这只是一个正常的生理周期。 是的。
你认为，就目前的比特币市场
周期而言，不是指形状和
模式，而是指现在
比特币市场中哪些方面与
2022 年或 2018 年相比并不明显
？ 我的意思是，我知道有
很多，但是你知道些什么呢？
哦，是的。
现在加密货币领域出现了许多积极的发展，与
四年前相比，如今的情况截然不同。如今，
世界上最强大的国家支持
加密货币，而四年前的情况则
完全相反，
美国政府甚至对加密货币发动了战争。所以，
我们现在所处的境地是怎样的呢？而且，
由于美国对加密货币的立场发生了
180度的转变，其他国家都
在效仿。现在，美国在
加密货币监管框架和相关
讨论等方面都处于领先地位。仅这一点就足以说明
巨大的变化，
我们看到了非常强劲的
机构采用。 贝莱德（Black Rock）……嗯……
所有ETF，包括BNB ETF，都已上市……
嗯……上周上市，然后……嗯……
机构参与度比四年前高得多……
嗯……四年前没有的。
嗯，生命周期基本上就是这样，
你知道，因为之前的美国证券交易委员会（SEC）
起诉了所有加密货币领域的人，所以
没有实用代币被
开发出来，大家都去了模因币
领域。但现在我们看到实际上有
更多真正的开发，所以现在
有更多开发者回到
美国，他们中的许多人在上届政府执政期间离开了美国，
因为当时的政府对加密货币非常
敌视。   是的
。
嗯，现在我们看到，我们看到
更多的发展了。 所以，现在
每个国家都在发行更多稳定币
。 嗯，还有更多我们称之为
现实世界资产的东西。 现在你可以
在币安上购买 SPEX 的 preIPO 代币了
。   是的
。
嗯，还有很多其他的交流。
嗯，是的，还有很多事情正在发生。 嗯，
我真的很兴奋。 所以，即使
我们谈论的是循环，但
循环的终点并不相同。 每个
周期都比上一个周期高得多
。   是的
。 我倾向于认为，
你提到的年度低点或
周期低点就像一个一直在
上升的底部。 当
人们说“哦，不，比特币并没有起到
数字黄金的作用”时，我往往会想到这一点。 我当时就想
，“不，不，那是
地下正在生长的数字黄金，它一直在
增长，然后，你知道，
投机者进来，把
上面的一切都炒作起来。” 看起来确实如此
，
你知道，我们已经达到 6 万了。 嗯，这种
底部上涨的趋势是长期持有者将
其用作类似数字黄金的
资产。
我记得比特币好像两年前才涨到 6 万美元
？ 呃，你知道，如果我们
说两四年前，如果我们
说比特币可以达到 50 美元，
那么在 21 年，我认为它达到了。
哦，确实如此。  21年
达到了那个水平，
我的意思是，
那是历史最高水平，对吧
。 没错，现在我们就像跌到了
谷底[笑声]。
我们是否已经触底反弹了？ 你认为
在这个周期中，底部会在哪里？
我在这方面从来都不准确，而且我也不喜欢
做预测，但是，嗯，之前的
最高点通常是未来的支撑位。 所以，就像
四五年前 6 万曾是历史最高纪录一样，
现在我们觉得这个数字非常低。
呃，通常来说，这些支持心理因素，
以及心理和
技术因素，都是造成这种情况的原因。 那些以
60,000 的价格买入的人，当
价格回到 60,000 时，他们可能会
套现。 那些以
6 万块钱买入的人，
现在不会卖了吧。 所以，呃，你涨到了
12 万，他们就降下来了。 所以他们会
买更多。   是的
。 这就像是提高了成本基础。   是的
。 是的。 因此，在技术分析中，
前一个高点总是会成为
下一个低点的支撑位。 所以，嗯，这
背后有很多……嗯，有很多……理论。 我不
知道这些话是真是假。 呃，我不是
什么技术分析师，但我觉得
你知道，感觉就是这样。 是的。
好的。 然后，我们就不再
讨论周期问题了。 我觉得还有一点很不一样，从历史
最高点到目前的回落，以及
这个周期与 2022 年的周期相比，肯定有
两点不同。之前的暴涨
和裸市要么是以
加密货币行业的重大暴涨为特征，要么就是由这些暴涨引起的，而这些暴涨往往与对
收益的不健康追求有关，或者说
收益往往是这类暴涨的核心。
嗯，你认为是否还有一些尸体
尚未被冲上岸？
因为自去年十月以来，我们还没有真正听说过
这件事
。 你
心里是不是在想，是不是还有一些我们不知道的尸体还
没有浮出水面？
这确实是个非常有趣的问题
。 我对此很好奇。 嗯，
甚至可能在6个月前，但
在过去的6个月里，没有
人说他们要
破产之类的。所以我认为这个行业
在控制
杠杆或无聊方面做得更好了。 嗯，所以，嗯，我认为
系统里确实出现了一些冲击，嗯，
但是没有人，没有人
破产等等。所以，但愿如此，是的，就我
所见，没有哪个平台真的破产，比如你知道的，像
FTX这样的借贷公司和交易所。 嗯，现在系统中是否存在危险的杠杆？
这次是
来自国库公司或链上交易的独特杠杆吗？
根据我对这个行业的了解（虽然只是行业
很小的一部分），你担心的是什么？
也许人们认为我
什么都懂，但实际上我只了解很小
一部分。嗯，我
目前并没有看到很多高杠杆产品。我记得之前有
一些稳定币提供了
高收益，比如
循环借贷之类的。但总的来说，
这些产品的规模相对于
现在的行业规模来说还是很小的。 所以，呃，我
今天没看到任何具有很大杠杆作用的重大事件发生。 是的。 所以，
希望这能带来好处，
实际上这是一件非常好的事。
好的，我们稍微继续一下。
让我们来谈谈华尔街，以及
我们所说的
传统金融和加密货币之间的巨大融合。
这事肯定正在发生。 加密货币
正在构建代币化的证券、现实
世界的资产等等。  Tradfi正在
整合加密货币或基于新的
区块链进行构建。 绝对地。
嗯，假设它们最终确实达到了
融合的停滞状态。 你
认为去中心化
和中心化之间的界限最终会在哪里？
Treadfi 会使加密货币更加
中心化，还是加密货币会使 TRDFI
更加去中心化？
嗯，我觉得这两件事都会发生。 正如你
所说，我们已经看到了这种趋同现象
。 理论上
也不应该出现融合的情况，加密货币
并非一个独立的行业。 加密货币
只是一种新技术、一种新工具，它能够
以
更快的速度、更低的成本、更
透明的方式促进金融交易等等。所以，它只是一种
新工具。 嗯，这就好比你知道，嗯，呃，
没有互联网公司，对吧？ 所以
就有像思科之类的互联网基础设施
公司，对吧？
正确的？ 呃，你不用像以前那样做实体
书店，
你可以创建一个线上版本，
而且可以发展壮大。它不一定非得
是一家纯粹的电商公司，对吧？
所以，现在，我们
所说的传统金融公司也
可以使用区块链。区块链对
任何人都是开放的，他们可以使用这项新技术，
他们可以使用比特币区块链，他们也可以
开发自己的区块链。
有很多不同的
技术，而且
大多数都是开源的，
所以任何人都可以采用这项
技术。 而对于加密货币
公司、加密货币从业者来说，他们可以提供
与传统金融服务非常相似的服务
。 现在他们可以提供
贷款、储蓄，还可以交易股票。 所以，嗯……
汇款、支付，所有
这些加密货币都能做到。 而且它们
并不一定局限于加密货币。
他们现在正在整合稳定币。
他们有法币交易渠道。 它们也像
法定货币一样运作
。 所以，他们不应该有这样的
划分。 应该只有一个。 这
应该只是
金融行业的问题。 这是金融科技
行业。 嗯，现在它已经更加
全球化了。 嗯，新的
区块链技术速度更快、成本更低。 许多
加密货币从业者并不做很多
传统的事情，他们的结构也
不同。 所以，嗯，我认为我们
肯定会看到这种情况，我们
肯定会看到这种收敛，
嗯，严格来说不应该出现收敛
。 它只是一个行业而已。 嗯，我
觉得这在去
中心化与中心化
方面是个好消息。 是的。 行业内的任何平台、任何公司都是
集中化的一部分。 任何
团队或任何项目，只要涉及不止
一个人，都属于集中式管理。 是的。
正确的。 所以，你知道，人类之间
存在网络效应。 我们喜欢，我们
通常以团队形式工作。 嗯，
很少有人能独自使用人工智能，这
可能会在某种程度上改变现状，但我们
通常需要一个团队。
嗯，而且这项技术一直在
发展，变得越来越去
中心化，所以我认为
中心化和去中心化都会出现。我认为很多人对中心化
和去中心化
持有一种二元对立的看法，但
在去
中心化的世界里，任何人都可以
一起工作，对吧？ 所以，去
中心化的世界应该能够容纳
中心化的参与者。
如果中心化运营商能够以
低成本提供真正优质、
非常安全的服务，那么他们就会吸引越来越
多的用户。 这里存在网络效应。
嗯，这会导致小规模的
集中化群体。 当然，
垄断
有利有弊，我们在历史上已经看到了很多这样的例子
。 嗯，是的。 所以，
滥用垄断权力的公司
通常会随着时间的推移而失去市场垄断地位
。 可能需要一段时间，但这终究
会发生，他们只是提供了新的
入门机会。 所以，嗯，我认为，是的，它们
在某种程度上总是会共存的，但
我强烈支持去
中心化。 嗯，我认为这项
技术将
在12月继续向前发展，越来越多的工具将
变得越来越去中心化。 一些
银行和卡组织现在正在
构建自己的区块链，因为我
认为（你说得完全对），
你可以在去
中心化平台上建立业务，但我认为
他们一直不愿让自己的
资产转移到去中心化
平台上。
所以，即使是他们中的一些人也在构建
半中心化的区块链。
例如，万事达卡
宣布了新的区块链，MTN 和 Circle 也都在构建以稳定币为中心的区块链。当然，
这些区块链的去
中心化程度各不相同，但 Tether、
Circle 和 Stripe 等都在构建
专注于稳定币的区块链。 现在拥有 Canton，
它来自数字资产。 所以它就
像是
经典许可型区块链的下一代迭代产品。
你知道，这就是
他们为什么不在 BNB、
以太坊、Solana 上构建应用，以及他们是否应该这样做的原因吗？
哦，好的。我认为，在一个去中心化的
世界里，如果你强迫每个人都在
特定的区块链上构建，或者任何人都
可以构建自己的区块链，这就是去
中心化的精神所在。
然后我认为，区块链种类越多，
对消费者来说实际上就越好，在
某种程度上，对吧？有时这会导致消费者感到
困惑，流动性分割
等等，但总的来说，选择越多越好。随着
时间的推移，消费者
会清楚地知道
哪些区块链会有
用。
而且，目前还不清楚
大多数人是否只
关心中心化的去中心
化。 我认为大多数人
关心的是低成本、安全、
易用性以及这些基本方面。
嗯，我们大多数人都是
铁杆比特币爱好者或者
加密货币玩家。 是的。
然后我们来谈谈去中心化。
我们明白其中的含义，
但大多数人只关注
结果，对吧？ 所以他们想要的只是
低成本、易用性、
安全性和自由。 嗯，所以如果那些
家伙，你知道，传统的，大型
金融机构，如果他们
想开发自己的
专有区块链，并且他们以
某种方式让人们使用它们，那么就
值得称赞。 但我认为越来越多的
人会要求更大的自由，
因为现在出现了
真正去中心化的加密货币
世界，它拥有更高的
自由度和更低的成本等等。所以
这给他们带来了压力，迫使他们也变成
那样。 假设几家大
公司开发了一种
稳定币，这种稳定币运行在
他们自己的区块链上，但你不能把它
转账给世界另一端的人，
那么他们就会限制它的使用。所以
我认为人们有这种需求，
我们想要能够以
低成本与世界上的任何人即时交易，而无需
担心国界。
当然，合规性也很
重要。所以，
最终取决于
消费者选择使用什么。 是的，
我觉得这种看待问题的方式很合理
。 我个人也认为，
私有许可区块链，不
妄加评判应该给哪个区块链贴什么标签，
嗯，它感觉有点像
企业互联网，
而公共的、无需许可的
通用区块链更像是
开放互联网。 是的。
所以，也许存在一个中心辐射状的网络，如果
他们出于某种原因仍然待在
自己的四面墙内，他们希望网络能够接入
他们的系统，但如果他们能够架桥（但愿如此，
如今架桥风险很大），但如果他们能够以某种方式
与更广阔的网络连接起来，这就有点像
宇宙论题了。   是的
。 所以你有很多，就像
我们称之为轮毂和辐条一样，
还有轮毂。 轮辐和轮毂都对。
所以，这完全有可能，就像你看，
很多国家
并不完全
接受纯粹开放的
区块链，他们都想要
自己的国家区块链，
是这样吗？是的，就像我和
很多
国家领导人讨论的那样，他们都
想要一个国家区块链，对吧？这很
有意思。
但这只是人类心理的问题，
他们需要时间来接受放弃对
资金的控制权，或者
放弃
对本国金融行业的控制权。所以，这
可能只是一个过渡阶段，
随着时间的推移，它会不断发展。
而且，对于像美国这样的大国来说，
即使
华尔街都使用一两个
区块链，而且这些区块链是
专有的，所有的大玩家都使用它们，
你仍然会看到数万亿
美元的资金在这些网络中流动，这没
问题。散户
可能不使用，甚至被排除在外，
但这也没关系，只要
企业互联网上有
足够的活动就行了。 就这样吧，这样就达到了目的，
所以基本上各人有各人的做法，我们
看看结果如何吧。   是的
。 是的。 所以我觉得，尤其是在
我们提倡
去中心化的时候，去
中心化和
每个人都必须使用开源的
单一区块链是不同的，如果我们
强迫每个人都使用比特币，那
实际上并不是去中心化。
没错，那基本上就是专制主义[笑声]
。 是的，没错。
所以这有点违反直觉。 没错，你说得很
有道理。 嗯，我们还是聊点
其他的话题吧。 币安
打造了现代永续合约。
当然，PERS 现在很重要，以前也很重要，但
现在更是如此，它们已经成为
当今加密货币领域的关键金融工具，而且早在币
安之前就已存在。显然，BitMEX 是
最早提供 PERS 的交易所之一。我说的是，
币安现在提供的 PERS 就是
人们今天使用的 PERS，
他们对其进行了现代化改造。但
如果你还记得
2016-17 年 Arthur Hayes 在
BitMEX 上推出 PERS 的时候，以及后来，PERS 一直都是
一种非常重要且高效的金融工具，
对于那些懂得如何
正确使用它们的人来说，它们是一种很棒的金融工具。
现在看来，美国即将实现
加密货币合法化
。 所以，你可能会看到
大型期货市场，比如芝加哥商品交易所 (CME) 和 SIBO，以及
其他获得美国商品期货交易委员会 (CFTC) 许可的加密
货币交易实体，但也可能看到
股票交易。   是的
。
嗯，当它们正式进入美国
或任何主要市场时，像……
你知道的，所谓的“
离岸加密货币交易所”引领着
世界，会发生什么呢？因为即使在
今天，情况也是如此。 眼睑上翻也是一个例子
。   是的
。 是的。 哦，是的。 所以这里面有
很多有趣的启示。
嗯，就这样。 我觉得你问了一个很长的
问题。   是的
。 当然。 当然。 当然。 那里
东西还真不少。
嗯，首先，
永续期货并非
加密货币领域首创，它其实早已存在于
传统金融领域。我想应该是
（清嗓子）吧。
虽然
BitMax在2014年就匆匆推出了永续期货，但
币安起步较晚，直到
2019年才开始提供这项服务，也就是
五年之后。此外，还有一些
其他平台提供不同类型的永续期货，
可能不是按期结算，而是交割
期货。交割期货每周五都需要进行
结算和
展期。
币安最初推出永续期货时，其
用户基数最大，因此
拥有目前为止最佳的
流动性、最大的交易量、
最优的价格以及最低的
滑点等等。现在，像芝加哥商品交易所（CME）这样的
传统大型期货交易所也开始上
线期货了。
我认为这很好，因为
他们服务于一个我们以前从未真正服务过的市场。
币安从来没提供服务过，对吧？
所以，嗯，呃，币安从未向美国的那些机构提供服务
。 呃
，币安全球
并不为美国用户提供服务。
嗯，还有，嗯，呃，哪个会变
大呢？ 实际上，这其实是一个不太
重要的问题，至少对我
个人而言是这样。 只要有更多的
人交易加密货币，情况就会更好。
最有可能的是，如果芝加哥商品交易所 (CME)、Seabot 或
其他美国交易所
能够让所有机构交易加密
货币期货，这将增加
流动性，因为会有人
能够在两个平台上进行交易，从而
弥合流动性差距，
为加密货币交易提供更多流动性，
我认为这真的很好。
所以，呃，我不太关心
谁必须比另一个人更大。
我认为，越多的人能够进行
加密货币交易，
流动性就越好，而流动性
越好，实际上是
对消费者最好的保护。
流动性充足的时候，
崩盘之类的事件就会少得多。是的。 而且
清算之类的事件也少得多，所以
保护措施更好。 然后，嗯，你抛出了
最后一部分，那就是现在加密货币
交易所正在像股票期货一样进行交易，
嗯，还有很多其他东西
他们还没有开始交易。 即使是
目前尚未交易的非结构化产品，也可能被结构化，
并足以在
区块链上进行交易，我
预测外汇交易将会转移到
区块链上。   是的
。
嗯，每个国家最终都会拥有
自己的稳定币，然后这些稳定币
就可以全天候在链上交易。
嗯，我认为外汇价格
发现实际上可能会在链上发生，
因为它更加
透明、更容易观察，也
更加持续。 所以我认为所有这些
事情都会发生。 这会对
传统的股票市场等产生负面影响吗
？ 我也这么认为。
但至少就
我所见，币安生态系统的
用户是完全
分离的，对吧。 所以，你
知道，如今住在
纽约和美国其他地方的人
可以随意购买股票，但
大多数其他国家的人却
买不到，对
他们来说购买美国股票并不容易。 他们当中有些人
可以，但实际上，
从
人口比例来看，这只占很小一部分人。 哪个国家不希望
全世界的人都能买到这些股票呢？ 所以你看，如果
你让 SpaceX 上市，你为什么不希望
全世界的人都购买它的股票呢
？ 哪家公司不想要这样的结果呢？
哪个证券交易所不希望这样呢？
哪个国家不希望
全世界的人都购买本国的政府债券呢
？ 你为什么要阻止其他
人购买你的政府债券？
嗯，所以，你看，如果一个国家大量购买
你的政府债券，这
实际上是你们避免冲突的最简单原因
[笑声]对吧？
所以你们必须就
贸易进行谈判，而不是互相攻击。所以，嗯，
所以，我认为世界正在变得越来越
小，即使存在
所有地缘政治紧张局势等等，我认为
世界正在变得越来越小。
而且，我认为加密货币交易所为
不在
该国的人提供购买该国股票的渠道，这并
不会损害
该国现有的证券交易所。 嗯，实际上它确实有帮助，比如
更好的流动性、更好的
需求等等。所以，是的，这就是我的看法。
好的。 我赞同你关于
增加股票获取渠道是
股票代币化的主要好处之一的观点。
嗯，我也调查过这个问题。 我
发现它时感到很惊讶。 事实上，
对很多人来说，购买
股票的成本太高了。 在这里，你知道，
你可以直接
在 Cash App 或 Venmo 上购买它们。 呃，但我的
意思是，这其实很容易。 但是，你
知道，我听说在一些国家，即使只是想
开一个
可以在那里交易美国存托凭证的账户，或者想
通过
相应的经纪商进行
交易，也需要非常高的
最低存款额。 你知道，5000美元，
你知道，世界上大多数人
实际上连最低存款都拿不出来。 是的。
嗯，是的。
每笔交易的金额大约在 2% 到 5% 之间。
正确的。
正确的。 那么，你可以交易多少次？
所以，嗯，呃，还有，还有
很多部分你根本无法访问。
你想支付多少保费都无所谓
。
就是塞不进去。
你只要获得访问权限就行了。
我想问一下关于眼睑下垂的问题。 这是
今年迄今为止为数不多的真正带来正面回报的加密货币之一。 嗯，但
显然也是一个规模庞大且不断发展的
平台。 我认为它的去
中心化程度比币安更高，但又不如
像Unis Swap这样的公司那么去中心化
。 介于两者之间。
嗯，你见过杰夫吗？ 你
对超流体有什么看法
？
当然。 当然。 嗯，我们和 Hyperlid 之间有一些
有趣的过往，
特别是和 Jeff 有关的那些事，我之前并不知道。 呃，我从没见过他
本人。 嗯，他实际上参与了
最早的几个简易实验室孵化
季之一，
对吧？
嗯，所以我猜他是个非常聪明的
年轻人。 嗯，他显然非常有能力。
嗯，所以，你知道，这背后有着一段很长的
历史，而且我认为
超流体的发明实际上
非常棒。 嗯，他证明了一个新的、原本
不存在的市场空白。 嗯，这一点
之前并没有被其他人证实过。
于是，他创造了新的事物。 嗯，这
很有意思。 嗯，而且
他团队的规模似乎很小。 嗯，
而且，嗯，我相信你也知道，嗯，那个
团队非常有能力。 嗯，它们
占据了一个币安交易所
无法与之竞争的市场空白。 嗯，你知道，他们
没有进行KYC验证。 嗯，他们声称
自己是去中心化的。 嗯，我再次声明，我不会
对其他项目发表评论。 嗯，
根据我们看到的技术，
他们拥有很大的控制权。嗯，
控制平台的团队很小。嗯，
所以这是否合理呢？他们
使用智能合约进行存款和
取款，并声称这是去
中心化的。嗯，我不想
深入探讨它的定义，这不是
我该做的。但他们服务于一个细分市场，
比如在美国，如果你有VPN就
可以使用它，对吧？所以大家都知道。
嗯，是的，嗯，他们的
交易量相当可观，而且
他们能够服务于
币安无法服务的许多用户。 呃，我再次重申，我
无权评论这
究竟是好是坏。 嗯，
他们有一些技术
创新，我认为这相当
不错。 是的。   是的
。 嗯，既然你
提到了这一点，那么我也知道，
没有 KYC 认证的加密货币交易所历史上有很多因此惹上
麻烦的人。
他们应该这样吗？是的。 他们应该
担心吗？
我绝不会做他们做的事。 嗯，就
我人生中的经历而言。 嗯，但
我不是法人。 我无法给
别人提供建议。 嗯，我不知道，嗯，
我再次认为他们应该有很好的
律师。 嗯，他们赚了很多
钱。 嗯，所以我猜他们会检查、
处理，他们都是大块头。 他们能
应付。
这是一个合理的答案。 嗯，所以不是按
市场划分的。 我认为，预测市场是新兴的突破性领域之一，
它不一定是加密货币，虽然
Poly市场
是最大的，
或者至少是最大的独立市场，它
建立在加密货币之上。你
对预测
市场有什么看法？你知道，很多司法管辖区都
在美国境内，某些州对此感到
不满，而其他国家要么在
努力应对，要么试图
监管，要么对此感到不满。
但同时，它们似乎也
相当有用，尤其是在
某些情况下，你必须
交易事件的替代品而不是
事件本身。无论是
监管方面还是
产品本身，你
现在如何看待预测市场？
我也认为这是一个非常巧妙或
很棒的发明。其实这并不是什么新发明，
预测市场已经存在
一段时间了，事件期货
预测市场。
我记得曾经在一个名为In
Trade的平台上交易，我记得它好像是在
英国运营的，比如2008年美国总统大选的时候，
我可以在那里交易。
是的，他们会推出目标，对吧？ 所以，
正如你所说，这感觉
有点像赌博，对吧？ 你
打赌就像是在
预测某个事件的结果。
呃，再说一遍，我不是律师。 嗯，
我猜想
关于这个特定行业，不同地方有很多不同的法规
。 嗯，但感觉上，
至少在我
听过一些演讲之后，比如美国
商品期货交易委员会（CFTC）主席迈克尔·西利奇的演讲，他在
很多演讲中都非常
支持，至少从语气上看是这样。
我不知道法律
定义是怎么规定的，但
至少从语气上看，他非常
支持。
美国很多重要机构的官员也
我个人认为这是一件好事。
我认为任何能让
人们发现
价格、发现流动性的东西都是好的。
这
在现实世界中有很多影响，比如为更好地
预测天气提供资金等等。
你知道，预测
在我们的生活中很重要，我们都希望
能够更好地预测事物。所以，在真金白银投入的情况下，
我认为
预测市场
比其他任何预测都更准确，
因为任何做出正确
预测的人都会…… 参与这些市场，
嗯，这其中蕴含着一些非常非常非常
有趣的意义。
嗯，我是……你知道的，我创办了其中一家
交易所。 嗯，我喜欢任何能够
提供价格发现和
流动性的工具。 所以我认为这很棒。 嗯，
还有，我相信
Poly Market Koshi
在美国都有牌照，所以这对我来说也很棒。不，这意味着
我不知道你刚才提到过，
有些州可能不喜欢
它等等。是的，因为原因
在于，他们有预测
市场，而吸引他们的
是他们对体育比赛结果的预测市场，这在
历史上被认为是体育
赌博，而体育赌博在美国历来都是一项受到各州严格监管的
活动，这就是
他们不满的原因。
好的。 所以这只是州与
联邦之间的区别，
因为你说得对，美国商品
期货交易委员会（CFTC）也在
法律上采取了强硬立场
。 他们参与了多起案件，为
加密货币预测市场公司对抗
国家提起诉讼。 他们加入了预测市场，或者
提交了支持预测市场的法庭之友意见陈述，
并且他们正在发布
新的预测市场规则制定框架，而该框架
本身的存在就是一种
支持。 是的，他们表示
支持，而且美国商品期货交易委员会（CFTC）也
非常明确地主张其在
预测市场方面对各州的联邦至上地位。 所以这里有一种
有趣的政府间合作，好吧，
但是，是的，你说得对，
他们表示支持。 好吧，我其实
不知道这些细节。 是啊，我
一直都远离政治，对吧？
所以，任何形式的管辖权纠纷，
我都会避而远之。 但我认为，对于
消费者而言，对于全球
加密货币行业而言，这是一件好事。 嗯，嗯嗯，
但是就像任何新技术、新
平台一样，只要他们做得好，
你就会非常出色。 嗯，
总会有把事情搞砸的方法。 但我认为
如今规模较大的公司表现非常出色。 而且
我认为未来还会涌现出很多新的
预测市场。
就像[笑声]加密货币领域一千多个
预测市场
项目一样。 所以我希望
他们都能
负责任地执行这项任务。 是的。   是的
。 嗯，我们来谈谈你
之前提到的一些事情，比如
更多的区块链，更多的消费者
选择，你知道，这是好事，当然现在
有很多，而且以后可能
会更多。
目前加密货币领域的大部分活动，我不想
说是中心化的，它有点……嗯，集中在
以太坊、Solana、BNB、Tron 等项目上。
你知道，之后这些项目可能会逐渐衰落，
但还有一些其他项目。BNB
无疑已经巩固了其
顶级区块链的地位，它也是一种顶级
资产。
你知道 BNB 现在最令人兴奋的地方是什么吗？
我们应该关注它，当然，
作为研究人员，也应该关注它
。
当然。 当然。 所以现在我不喜欢我没有
运营交易所。 实际上，我现在有更多的
时间和社区里的开发者们交流
。 我其实对
他们在 B&B 连锁酒店上开发的一些新功能感到非常兴奋。 嗯，
他们，所以，我给
开发者的建议之一是，不要在
牛市期间进行大规模升级，但在裸
市期间，市场比较平静，你可以
进行大规模升级。 所以我
建议所有区块链开发者都这样做，而不仅仅是
B&B区块链开发者。
嗯，他们现在正在开发下一个
版本，这个版本速度更快，价格更
便宜，并且为
用户提供更多隐私控制功能。 嗯，
功能列表很长，我看到的时候
就想，我其实不是个很有
想象力的人。 我不
开这些东西。 但是
当我看到他们和
他们交谈，看到
他们正在开发的功能列表时，我就想，哇，
你将在一个版本中获得所有这些功能
。
呃，所以他们正在建造它。 他们给
即将进行的这次升级起名字了吗？
我其实还不知道名字。 我想
他们应该有个代号，但我忘了。
好的，我们会核实一下，然后我会把它写进
节目笔记里。
当然。 当然。 不，我忘了。 嗯，我和
开发人员谈过，你知道，
但我并不负责运营，对吧？ 所以，
这就是他们的动力。 嗯，是的。
所以，呃，
这是否意味着要和
Solana 之类的项目竞争呢？Solana
几年前
凭借比以太坊更快更便宜的优势横空出世。
你知道，你还有
其他一些区别。 嗯，隐私问题
最近也一直是个热门话题。
这样做仅仅是为了
改进它，
还是因为有竞争对手？我不知道
半去中心化或分散式的L1
开发团队是如何看待这种大型升级的
？
当然。 当然。 嗯，我觉得……不，我
觉得不存在与
特定连锁店的竞争。 我觉得萨洛纳大概是在
四五年前，或许更
久一点的时候开始转变的。
嗯，然后，呃，最初它本来会得到
FTX 的支持，就像
SPF 那样。   是的
。 呃，后来
由于 FTF 的崩溃，他们遭受了相当大的损失，但很
高兴看到他们恢复过来。 是的。
所以这展现了去
中心化区块链的韧性。 嗯，Salona，嗯，
当 B&B 链刚开始的时候，嗯，
有很多关于
B&B 链过度中心化的指责，
因为它的节点比
以太坊少，但 Salona 的节点要少得多
。 所以
节点数量和性能之间总是存在一种平衡，
对吧？ 节点越少，同步速度越快，
所需时间越短
。 我认为以太坊仍然
像他们想要成为的那种
完全去中心化的神圣存在。 所以对他们来说，每一次升级都
非常困难。 是的。 所以，这其中肯定存在某种
平衡
。 嗯，我觉得B&B ch
就像……我不知道。 我记不起来了。 我
其实不知道。 就像有 41 个节点
或 100 个节点一样。 我其实不知道。
我们会考虑，也会把它考虑进去
。  [笑声] 别担心。
不用担心。
菲尼亚斯，比如，技术方面，怎么才能把电脑弄进来？ 查
一下。   是的
。   是的
。 所以，嗯，还有，但我认为，
萨洛纳的崛起和复苏与其说是
去中心化与非去中心化的问题，不如说是去中心化与非
去中心化的问题。 呃，是因为
他们非常热衷于表情包
领域。 嗯，他们
在美国也做了非常出色的市场推广，而当时的
民宿连锁店根本没有做任何市场推广
。 嗯，他们也确实如此，所以他们让
更多美国开发者加入了
区块链。在上届
政府执政期间，币安链
试图远离美国，或者任何与
币安链相关的业务。币安，包括我自己，都尽量
远离美国。而且，
在
上届
政府执政期间，美国证券交易委员会（SEC）起诉了
所有加密货币项目，这使得
推出一个具有实用性的加密货币项目变得非常困难。这就是
为什么所有那些所谓的“模因
币”都鼓励
交易扩散的原因。而Salona
在FDX倒闭后，就再也没有交易所与之关联了。 所以
他们就说，嗯，他们就说，
他们，他们经常用“拉高
出货”这个词，对吧？ 所以，这里有一个
叫做 pump pump 的平台。
在民宿连锁生态系统中寻找乐趣。 如果
出现一个叫做“泵”的平台，那么
监管力度肯定会加大
，对吧？ 所以就像在 BMBB
链上，因为有币安
这样的大型交易所，而 B&B
链虽然是一个
完全独立的区块链，
但我们仍然处于
某种更紧密的生态系统中。 而且
我们受到的
监管机构审查也更加严格。 任何在
BMBB 生态系统中被称为“泵入”或“泵入”的东西
都会受到更严格的审查。 是的。
所以机会都
冷漠地增长了，嗯，嗯，但是我觉得
这很好，对吧。 所以，嗯，我认为这对这个
空间来说其实非常好。 如果空间中只有一个通道，
那么调节器
现在可能已经关闭了。
事实上，拥有多个区块链
是一件好事，它们
在不同的时间、不同的地方迅速发展，
这实际上有助于
整个行业的增长。 所以我觉得这真的
很好。 我认为
萨洛纳的康复情况非常出色，
简直令人惊叹。 是的。   以太
坊社区走上了一条
道路，他们在 Salona 之前就一直在走这条路，
但后来
由于第一层区块链
高度去中心化，他们自己的中心辐射型模型变得尤为迫切。 所以他们推广了
L2 理论，但如今的 L2
主要都是乐观的单
序列器汇总，并没有
真正去中心化，而且我认为没有
任何一个 L2 真正达到了去
中心化的第二阶段。 嗯，你
对这个论点有什么看法？我知道
Vitalic 似乎说过，
也许我们应该
再次加大对 L1 的研发投入。   是的
。 是的。 你知道，
嗯，我确实感觉到了
Vitalik 语气的变化，而且，嗯，还有，是的，
我想大概是在四五年前，
以太坊社区都在
谈论 L2 层。   是的
。
嗯，我觉得在过去
几年里，他们有点
改变了方向，停止了运营，
因为现在最大的
基地基本上是由一家
公司运营的。 我的意思是，有
一些安全措施是可以的。 并不是说
你拥有单方面退出的
能力。 是的。
但你知道，排序器可以对交易进行排序
，收取任意费用，
等等。
确切地。 确切地。 所以 L2 层不是
非常集中，而是极其集中。
所以现在，极端社区
想要推广完全
去中心化，但是所有的 L2 层都是
超级中心化的。 然后，嗯，所以，
还有，L2 级设备也不行，但我
认为这不是主要原因。
我认为主要原因是 L2
对 L1 没有贡献，对吗？ 所以
他们知道，L2 只需要
一次性花费以太坊，比如
批量花费，对吧？ 所以他们
实际上并没有做出贡献。
我认为我们已经计算过了，我们发现
Bass 为
选择 Optimism Foundation
使用该技术而支付的许可费比他们实际
支付的以太坊 L1 费用还要多。
哦，远远超过。 大概高出
两到三个数量级吧？ 所以，嗯，
然后，嗯，最终他们，我想
Vitalic 意识到 [笑声]
L2 缓存对 L1 缓存没有帮助，然后
以太坊经历了一段时期，
Vitalic
因为
以太坊的价格表现而承受着很大的压力，
网上有很多关于他的笑话，说实话，这对他是不公平的
。 但我认为，
所有这些因素加在一起，让他
意识到他仍然需要继续开发
L1。 所以现在他稍微转移了一下注意力，
这对于他来说并不正常，你
知道，你会尝试
不同的事物。 完全。 是的。 所以，嗯，
就像你说的，现在仍然有
一些非常
强大的 L2，但我认为未来
仍然是 L1。 说
实话，它可能就像，呃，
该怎么称呼它呢？ 嗯，这种情况会持续
一段时间，比如我们知道 L1 设备速度会越来越
快，但需求会随之
而来，而 L1 设备又无法如此
快速地扩展，因此未来可能还会
出现其他 L2 类型的解决方案
。 他们又会像以前那样来回
摇摆。 我
认为，
如果
你是一家大型银行或其他机构，与其构建一条全新的链，不如
在现有链上实现某种形式的二级缓存（L2），
尤其是在该链本身就支持
安全桥接的情况下。
乐观滚动（Optimistic Rollups）并非如此，它们
不会桥接回一级缓存（L1），而是
直接集成。这
对于中心节点来说可能是一种有趣的连接方式，但这似乎
并非以太坊去
中心化主要
用户群体
目前真正想要的。不过，二级缓存或许也有其用武之地。
但是，尽管二级缓存非常中心化
，如果一批数据在处理后仍然
与一级缓存同步，那么它仍然是
不可篡改的。
这是正确的。
正确的。 所以，嗯，他们仍然觉得不行，他们
仍然知道这仍然比
现在银行可以随意
更改记录的情况要好。
您可以更改 10 年前的记录
。
正确的。 因为如果我要求 L2
处理从 Alex 到 CZ 的传输，
而音序器拒绝，我可以
直接在 L1 上重新播放。 所以你
可以……嗯，但这确实引出了一点，
你知道，L2
最大化主义者总是说，
单方面退出能力就像是
权宜之计，的确如此。但如果
交易不是简单的转账，而是
贷款抵押品的补充，或者类似的
交易，
即使你能退出，也会产生实际的影响。
你知道
我的意思，比如，如果我需要
补充流动性，或者我需要……
那就真的开始
出现问题了，对吧？或者
老实说，即使只是一笔交易，
我其实没想那么远，
但它必须马上完成，
哪怕晚一分钟也是个问题，
然后就得经历这个过程。这就是我……
你知道，如果排序器
选择在L2上审查你，
这是我经常考虑的一件事，尤其是在
代币化证券方面。
我们在Solana上对Galaxy股票进行了代币化，
我认为我们也会做其他通用
用途。我最初只是发行了一种
发行人担保的证券，但
我知道的一点是…… 我们
认为 L2 的去中心化程度不够高，不足以
成为我们想要进行交易的可信的中立平台
。 没错，确实如此
。 这是真的。 是的。
所以你实际上对此进行了
比我更深入的研究
。 是的。 不，我在这件事上投入了很多精力。
[笑声] 是的。
那么，我
想问一下关于 YZI Labs 的问题，它以前
叫做 Binance Labs。 它对您来说是一项核心
投资工具。
嗯，现在的核心论点是什么？
因为我看到他们以前
主要或全部都是加密货币。
现在我也看到一些人工智能和生物技术方面的
东西。
你们在YZI Labs做什么呢
？   是的
。 嗯，是的。 是的。 所以我给出一个
大致的指导原则，比如 70% 加密货币，20%
人工智能，10% 生物科技。 所以我认为这
三个领域都是很大的行业，它们将
继续蓬勃发展，而且这
三个领域还有很多很多新的
创新有待发现、有待实现、有待
构建，这些创新
基本上可以对我们的文明产生巨大的积极影响。 所以，嗯，呃，
简单实验室，呃，理念，我希望
他们投资是为了产生影响，而不是
为了获得财务回报。 嗯，
有时候他们可能会
分歧。 嗯，我举个极端的
例子，假设我们投资
十亿美元给一家药物研发
公司，这家公司可以治愈像癌症这样的常见疾病，
而且这种疗法非常便宜，
公司可能赚不到钱，
但它可以治愈一百万、一
千万、一亿人。 我
非常乐意损失那十亿到
几十亿美元的投资。 这
会让我非常开心，对吧？ 因为
我们拥有影响力。
而且，这也就像一笔数额较小的
本金投资。 我想，
损失的更多在于原本可以获得10亿美元的收益，
对吧？ 所以
，
从这个原因来说，在早期阶段以低价进行投资是很有吸引力的
。   是的
。 所以，是的，容易获得的资金，比如
寻找非常早期的项目，这类项目
很多都
有些疯狂。 所以它们的失败率非常高，这是
我们预料之中的。 但是，嗯，
我认为我们也投资了一些非常
好的项目。 嗯，
现在有没有哪些公司特别突出？
或者说，最近新出的一批公司，
或者最近出现的一些公司，有什么特别令人
兴奋的，你想
推荐的投资组合公司吗？
嗯，有很多加密货币
公司，我其实不会
谈论它们，因为我不想被
认为是在专门为它们做宣传，
它们中的很多都有代币。   是的
。
嗯，我们投资了一家人造子宫公司
。所以现在你
可以在机器里生孩子了，
对吧？ 所以，这让女性摆脱了
怀孕的过程，也让
男性免于
遭受攻击，嗯，不[笑声]
乞求女性提供
人工子宫。   是的
。 所以我认为他们实际上对
老鼠进行了妊娠中期试验。
所以我认为它们可能距离人类还有 5 到 10 年的时间
。
这就像为了
太空旅行而培育人类一样吗？
可能就像不同的应用场景非常
广泛一样。 所以，这就好比是衡量
人类是否被
圈养的标准一样。   是的
。 嗯，这就是我的意思[笑]，
我捐的更多是慈善性质的。 你
知道，我们实际上要在光年之外建立一个新
文明，所以我们把
飞船送去一千年，
最终它就在那里孕育了人类
。 我不知道。 那是我编的。
科幻概念相当不错。 所以，当
你说“人类被
圈养”的时候，要像人们能够理解这种做法的
正面和负面影响一样，而
我也理解这种技术可能会带来的影响。
但是，无论如何，这项技术
可以帮助很多人。 嗯，最近还有一种新的技术，它使用一种叫做
PLA（聚乳酸）的材料，而不是塑料，而是一种
3D打印的类似泡沫塑料的材料，可以
植入膝盖软骨中，让你的
软骨围绕它生长。 所以它能促进
膝盖软骨的生长。
哇哦。
许多老年人都有膝盖问题。
正确的。 呃，所以说，
膝盖出问题并不一定需要年纪很大。 我现在就告诉你。
确切地。 所以，呃，大概没有那种事
。 呃，而且这个也还比较
早。 他们还没正式开始。  U I
我不是 我忘了舞台。 他们
可能即将开始下一轮
人体临床试验。 嗯，诸如此类的事情，
我们还在人工智能机器人领域投入了大量资金
。 嗯，不过你知道吗，
其实真正让我兴奋的是生物科技公司
。 嗯，他们只是……不，
他们只是……这非常具体，就像有
一天你会帮助很多人一样，
人工智能机器人，
我们都知道它将会非常流行，而且
很酷。 是的。 但这
并不意味着你解决了
所有人的膝盖问题。 确切地。
那要具体得多。   是的
。 是的。 所以，
对生物科技行业的
投资存在一种心理上的回报。 嗯，是的，
我很喜欢。 嗯，我们来聊聊人工智能吧。
你们在投资人工智能吗？ 嗯，我们正在
建设一个人工智能数据
中心，此外我们也涉足
加密货币领域。
嗯，现在大家都在使用人工智能。 我
请 Galaxy 的员工
提交了一些问题。 大家最
想让我问的一个问题是：你个人
目前最喜欢使用哪种法学硕士学位？ 就像你知道的那样，我会在
它们之间切换。 你知道，人生总有起起落落
，但现在，你
喜欢什么呢？ 你最期待哪款人工智能手机应用
？
我几乎都安装好了。 嗯，
我全都订阅了。 嗯，
我根据不同的事情使用不同的词
。 嗯，OpenAI 是你第一个要
安装的软件，对吧？ 所以，就像它们是
最古老的 cl uh open uh uh anthrop uh
cloud uh 更适合编码，我
发现是这样，但我写的
代码不多，但它仍然很适合
回答问题。 我还发现，
不同的AI公司有时
在某些
国家/地区无法提供服务。 我经常旅行。 是真的吗？
有趣的。 所以我经常旅行。 所以当你
旅行时，你去的一些国家可能
没有一家人工智能公司提供服务。
你刚打开应用，它就显示“
抱歉，我无法为
这个国家提供服务”。 我感觉我就只能在
这里等三天了。
但你知道，接下来你就得去下一个地方
。 嗯，那里
也存在一些地缘政治紧张局势。
例如，我知道要去香港旅行的时候
。
嗯，美国的人工智能公司没有一家成功。 所以
你就用Deep Seek、Kimi，还有一大堆
中国人。 是的。
嗯，我不关心政治。 我心想，你看，我
只是用任何对我有用的东西，但我得
赶紧问这个问题。   是的
。 请问有人能回答一下吗？   是的
。 但总的来说，我确实
觉得美国
语言模型
更加精确、更加
准确。 嗯，虽然中国的
开源软件也很好，但
有时它们不够全面。   是的
。  Deep Seek um Kimmy 我自己在家也用过其中一些
。 嗯，
既然你提到了
地缘政治方面，我觉得这
很有意思。
很多人都写过一篇很棒的文章，题为《人工智能2027》。
你读过那篇文章吗？ 真的
很好。 之后我会分享给你。
我明白了，嗯，
这有点像你知道的，
从 25 到 207，可能会发生什么，
然后最终它变成了一个选择你
自己的冒险，就像加速主义者或
安全主义者一样。 是的。 嗯，你知道，
人工智能领域最引人瞩目的新闻之一，就是
中国宣布了超过2000亿美元的
国家投资用于数据中心建设。
当然，美国也有大量的
私人投资，但我认为也有很多
公共资金支持数据中心
建设和资本支出。
这会不会演变成
一场冷战式的AI
军备竞赛？它应该发生吗？它已经
发生了吗？
好吧，我再次声明，我不是这
方面的专家，但我确实认为
这肯定会是一场
竞赛，尤其是在
最近发生的事情之后。我的意思是，
不用看两家公司的销售数据就能
看出，中国肯定在研发
自己的芯片，对吧？中国
肯定在发展自己的数据
中心，两国都在努力发展数据中心，对吧？
美国也肯定在努力发展数据中心
制造，
所以这是一场竞赛。
但是，竞争是有益的，它
实际上可以促进增长，加快
增长速度。但我
认为在人工智能领域，我们 必须
谨慎对待增长速度，
因为人工智能非常强大，
可能会很危险，非常
危险。所以，现在很多人都
在关注加密货币监管，
很少有人谈论人工智能监管。那么，
人工智能和
加密货币监管之间有什么区别呢？其实很简单，就像
记录一样，
你基本上只是在处理金钱。除此之外并
没有太多其他的东西，当然，
还有KYC和AML，
但本质上都是和金钱相关的。
本质上，它只是一项新技术。
但人工智能还能做更多的事情。 人工智能可以入侵
你的电脑。 呃，他能想办法
制造核弹吗？ 人工智能可以做
很多不同的事情。 你可以
编写机器人程序。 呃，你可以对纳米机器人进行编程
。 呃，你可以像飞行
纳米机器人一样飞行。 比如，用它你能做什么，
不能做什么？ 嗯，
他们当然可以，他们显然可以对无人机进行编程
等等。所以人工智能的应用非常广泛，
但我认为没有人真正深入、
全面地思考如何
监管人工智能。 话虽如此，但当我
真正思考这个问题时，
却不知道该如何解决。 是的。 这
是一个非常棘手的问题，
因为你既想促进增长，又想促进
创新。 这不仅仅是
因为我们看到了一些提案，我
知道在美国可能到处都有类似的提案
。 你知道，现在有一股小
而壮大的民粹主义反弹浪潮，甚至有人呼吁完全取消
数据中心，不仅要确保
人工智能的安全，还要减少人工智能的建设，尽管这种浪潮
目前还没有占上风
，但我还没有看到
比你的观点更细致入微的论述
。
通常情况下，法规的最初版本
或人们的说法都过于非
黑即白。   是的
。
好的。 是的。 我们可以通过扼杀这个行业来规范它
，
对吧？
那不是监管，那是
杀戮。 监管行业
意味着你想促进它的使用
。 否则，你不需要
管它，直接把它杀掉就行了。 对，
那就是没有起到
监管作用，对吧？ 所以，嗯，是的，
但是人工智能真的很难监管。 呃，
很多人并没有深入思考或
讨论这个问题。 但仔细
想想这个问题，它实际上
对我们的文明非常重要。
人工智能、加密货币，无论它们做什么，它们都
没有能力毁灭我们的
文明。 嗯，它非常强大。
感觉这里面牵涉到很多钱，
你知道，这是一个
很棒的行业，它促进了全球
贸易，增长了我们的经济等等，但它
并非如此。如果我们不谨慎使用人工智能，它也有能力
毁灭我们的文明。
所以，嗯，是的，总之，我只是在
发牢骚。是的，
不，我[笑]很感激，
这正是我想要听到的。你知道，我最
喜欢的事情之一就是看
你
用Claw代码或其他什么东西在家用人工智能技术亲手构建一些东西，就像
大多数人都在摆弄东西一样。
这是我们最喜欢
问的问题之一，比如，弗兰克，
你在用人工智能构建什么？
嗯，我试过了，但是非常
不成功。 我试了开爪。 嗯，
呃，我把它安装在了我的一台
闲置的Mac电脑上。 呃，然后我试着
让它下载我的 Gmail，它
很容易就连接上了。 嗯，
我试着让它过滤我的电子邮件。
我收到好多垃圾邮件。   是的
。 哦，是的。
正确的。 我收到的垃圾邮件太多了，以至于
我都不用电子邮件了。
不，我也是。 情况很糟糕。
我根本不用电子邮件。
但我认为他很
擅长使用Gmail。 所以，就像下载了它，看看它能做什么，然后
把它插上，我拿到了一个 Gmail API 密钥，把
它放进去……但是它非常谨慎，
它非常顽固地阻止我
删除邮件。对我来说，我就想，哦，
删除所有垃圾邮件，只显示
那些重要的邮件，你知道的，
但是，
大概有 30% 到 40% 的邮件
都是请求和
我开会，对吧？
就像，这个人请求
和我开邮件会议，到处都是
这样的会议请求。 他认为这很
重要。
正确的。
正确的。 我和
你一样，觉得很多东西都是垃圾
。 是的。 收到的全是垃圾邮件。
我觉得其中99%都是
我不认识的人发来的垃圾信息。 正确的。 我不会
接受那些会面邀请。 但
我就像人工智能一样尝试了一下。 它根本无法满足我的需求
。
有趣的。 很有意思。 嗯，我们来
稍微聊聊量子力学吧。
之前我还
向一家投资银行做了一个关于比特币、
量子力学以及缓解措施的演讲。
你是否担心量子计算会对
比特币构成威胁？ 不，嗯……其实我一点也不
担心。 嗯，我认为
第一点是，计算能力越强
越好。 嗯，它们已经是
抗量子加密
算法了。 所以从概念上讲，我们只需要做一件
非常简单的事情，我们只需要
升级或更改加密
算法。 嗯，但是对于像比特币这样去中心化的
知识技术，以及
遍布世界各地如此多的用户来说，
协调是很困难的。
嗯，还有中本聪的比特币，
你知道，呃，我们需要
做什么等等。但总的来说，我并不
担心。 嗯，我
隐隐觉得，谷歌
说的是 2029 年。
是的。
嗯，那会非常好。是的，我的意思是，我很
感激。 不，他们确实给人
一种紧迫感。
有些情况紧急，有些情况需要提前
通知。 嗯，我不知道发生了什么事，
他们有什么事？ 或许他们
已经能够破解比特币了。 他们
不。 如果真是那样的话，我会
非常感激
他们没有那样做
。 是的。
嗯，但我认为更有可能的是，这其中可能
带有一些公关因素。   你看
，如果你是一名量子
研究人员，你希望量子领域获得更多关注，
你可能不会给出像
你说的2035年那样相对激进的预测。那样的话，没人会
去看那篇文章。 是的。   是的
。 你说那是真的。 正确的。
而且我认为，实际上，谷歌那篇论文
的主要作者之一
，长期从事量子研究的克雷格·吉布尼（Craig Gibney）在测试后
表示，他认为到
2029 年实现量子跃迁的可能性大约为 10%。
是的。 没错。 但我很欣赏这种
工程估算。
正确的。 正确的。  [笑声] 对。 说
实话，我认为
他们一直被这样推着走，
谷歌的那篇论文确实描述了一项
实质性的改进。 是的。
在数学上，因此
需要减少肘尺的数量。 就这样吧，
但不管怎样，那一天终会
到来。 是的。
那么比特币就必须
升级了。
嗯，所以，Eclipse 加密技术
需要升级。   是的
。 所以，呃，但是我们作为一个社区
需要以某种方式协调这件事。 嗯，所以
这是我们的任务。 嗯，目前有
一些早期工作正在进行，但我
想说现在还处于早期阶段，而且你也知道
比特币是多么去中心化，就像
以太坊基金会发布的完整
路线图一样。 太好了，好像
比特币界就没有这样的组织来做这件事似的。
[笑声]
嗯，不过我觉得我看到了一些复苏的迹象
。
但我认为，当形势变得
更加紧迫时，一些关键团体
将会聚集在一起，届时仍会
有很多辩论。 比特币甚至可能会出现
很多分叉，但最终
我们会达成目标。
是的，我一直在考虑风险，嗯，
我们比特币持有者以前经历过很多次
分叉，对吧？
比特币黄金、比特币钻石、比特币
现金、比特币，随便你怎么称呼它。 跟我说说吧
。
有趣的是，这种情况现在不常发生了
，但这曾经是
比特币发展史上的一个重要主题，
大概持续了三年左右，大概从
2016 年到 2018 年。分叉太多了，对吧？
不，更像是……嗯……更像是……
不，更像是……不，2017 年 8 月 20 日
是 BCH 的第一次分叉。
BCH，但在此
之前还有一些其他的。
所以在 BCH 分叉之后，
币安是第一个宣布
将支持两个分叉的交易所，
因为否则用户必须
从交易所下载比特币，
安装两个钱包，然后弄清楚
哪个是 SIG 的，哪个不是，
你知道的，而当时下载
整个比特币区块链需要
三四天时间。 嗯，他们
必须完成所有这些工作。 嗯，
币安是第一个交易所。 我提出了
这个想法，说，为什么不由我们来处理
用户的问题呢？因为我们有一个很大的
钱包，我们只需给用户
他们应该得到的 BCH，然后就
完成了，之后我们就可以上线 BCH 进行
交易了。
很少有人关注交易所。我当时在富达工作时做过一项研究，探讨
各个交易所是如何
处理 BCH 分叉的。 许多人什么也没做。
他们理论上掌握了钥匙，但他们
没有把 BCH 给你。  Coinbase 好像直到 12 月份才
给你发放 BCH 或允许你进行交易
。 我觉得
可能是 Bitfinex，他们
也想看看它未来会在哪里交易
，如果一定要分叉的话，这实际上是一件
非常重要的事情
。 是的，我记得币安就是其中
一家说过“我们会把它
给你”的公司。   是的
。
我认为有些人把它卖了，然后把
比特币收益给了你。 是的。
非常奇怪。
但是，反作用力是，这
帮助了
很多用户。 但随之而来的反作用是，
人们看到
币安支持比特币
分叉，因为我们想让用户享受到
这些好处。 所以后来出现了
比特币黄金、比特币钻石、比特币，
但实际上它们几乎都毫无用处。   是的
。 是的。
正确的。 但是，它们在
最初分叉时都有一定的价值，
所以，交易所被迫
支持其中相当一部分，然后过了
一段时间，我们说，好吧，我们
不得不停止了。 所以，
大概有三到
六个月的时间，出现了许多分支，
我们停止了对它们的支持。
比特币分叉时代真是令人
兴奋。 嗯，回到
你刚才提到的量子力学方面的问题。 假设我们
掌握了新的加密技术，
比特币爱好者决定将其添加进去，那么所有这
部分问题就都解决了。
比特币持有者或比特币是否应该对中
本聪的代币采取行动？ 我的
理解是，大概有
三种选择。 你可以什么都不做，
实际上就相当于赏金。
缺点显而易见，就是这些
币很可能有一天会被某个独立开发者抢走，
造成抛售压力。
但抛售压力最终会将它们重新分配
给社区，所以从长远来看，这其中还是有一定好处的，
相对于短期风险而言。有人
说，可以采取某种形式的
冻结和扣押措施，
如果他能拿出写着“中本聪”
或其他名字的护照，就把币还给他。
我知道这很棘手，因为
我们唯一能证明的就是
加密证明，而加密证明已经被
破解了。还有一种
折衷方案，比如
放慢支出速度之类的。
你觉得我的意思是什么？
我不太确定我的立场，
但
我认为第一个方案肯定不好。
我们应该采取一些措施。
但我其实想提出一个
不同的解决方案。我认为我们
应该说，一旦我们确定要
分叉比特币，就应该…… 我们应该，
我会提出第四个方案，比如
作为一个社区，我们为什么
不设定一个时间表，比如
6个月或12个月内，
如果这些代币没有转移，我们就
锁定它们。
这样，在新协议下，这些代
币将只有2000万枚，因为
我们将锁定它们，
移除100万枚，
这些地址将被冻结。在
镜像服务器上，这些地址也将被
冻结。我会说，我们给他一年时间，
如果他
一年内没有完成，我想，
我们给他时间，他可能还
活着，也可能已经不在
人世，谁知道呢。
所以，如果
我们什么都不做，我们
基本上就是把代币交给了会
破解它的人，第一个运行E
Quantum的人最终会破解它。
发生了，嗯，在我看来，这不是一种好的
分发方式，嗯，而且速度很
慢，所以我建议这样做，嗯，这就是
我最终会建议的做法，我
认为我们应该最终通过
社区投票来决定。 嗯，我不
知道该怎么做，你知道，我们可能
需要用比特币标志来发出信号。   是的
。 在比特币中，投票通常
类似于轻微的标记。   是的
。 少校旗。
你可以运行支持 UASF 的节点
，但这可能构成民事
攻击。 是的。   是的
。 是的。
这是一个棘手的问题。 坦白说，我认为这个问题没有
好的答案
，很遗憾。
不，不。我的确认为，如果他
什么都不做，那么我的
建议是，新的
方案应该被冻结，就像那些方案
将被停止流通一样。
知道了。   是的
。   最后还有
两个问题想问，这两个问题都比较
开放。
在过去一两年里，
你有没有改变过对某件事的看法
？
哦，这很简单。   是的
。   大约
一
年前或一年半前，我对RWAS还相当怀疑。 我当时想，
你知道，谁会喜欢这些东西呢？我
不确定是否有人会交易这些
东西。 我不确定它是否会
起飞，但它的起飞速度
确实让我感到意外。
嗯，所以我觉得，你知道，
稳定币、石油期货、人工智能股票等等，
它们在加密货币社区都得到了很好的推广
。 嗯，这意味着有
需求，嗯，这意味着
世界上很多人想要
获得这些东西，但他们却无法
获得。 嗯……这让我很
意外。 嗯，十年前我还不怎么关注
稳定币，但我早就对稳定币失去了兴趣
。   是的
。 是的。
最后一个问题，CZ，
你是在2017年创立币安的，对吧？   有什么
事情，无论是
你今天认为显而易见的，还是你今天仍然深信不疑的，与
你当时认为显而易见并深信不疑的事情一样？   一直以来，
你始终坚持的信念是什么
？ 嗯……
等等。 请问，
您是指从商业机会的
角度还是从信仰的角度出发？
是的，
我会说这是一种信仰
视角。 你创立币安时，
对它充满信心，
今天你的信心依然不变，甚至更加
坚定。 可以是想法、
概念。
好的。 好的。 就这么简单。 我的意思是，加密货币
不会消失。 加密货币将会成为
一个庞大的产业。 嗯，所以，情况并没有
改变。 嗯，所以这种信念现在只会
变得更加更加强烈。
嗯，所以，呃，是的，我不知道该
怎么用简单的语言解释。 它只会越来越
大。 嗯，实际上它没有办法再
缩小了。 嗯，
价格肯定会波动。   是的
。
嗯，就个别加密货币而言，嗯，整个
行业将会发展壮大。 嗯，
你知道，现在有很多热钱
涌入了人工智能领域，大家都在追逐所有的
人工智能股票。 极好的。 你猜怎么着？
现在人们都在用加密货币交易人工智能股票了。 人工智能实际上正在
促进加密货币的交易量。
嗯，这或许对加密货币本身有帮助，也或许没有
。 加密货币本身就是一部分，但
现在人们正在使用区块链
来访问这些东西。人工智能虽然
现在很火，但它还不能
替我们进行交易。所以，现在它们可以帮
我们找到最便宜的机票，但我们
仍然需要自己支付机票费用。
代理交易和支付等等，
你可能觉得
它们会很快普及，但
我认为不会几年。
而且它们
会使用加密货币。想象一下，
如果你今天推出这项服务，或者
你有一个代理可以帮你买
票、交易等等，你可以逐个
国家地整合支付系统，或者你可以说
我们要启用加密货币支付。而且，
目前很多
支付系统都无法与人工智能兼容。
人工智能无法刷你的Visa卡，你
或许可以填写表格，但每当需要双因素认证（
2FA）时，比如
KYC（了解你的客户）如何出示你的护照，人工智能都无法
做到。而区块链则可以做到这一点。
它是 API 驱动的，对吧？所以，
人工智能更容易……所以，
虽然人工智能很棒，人工智能只是帮你
完成工作的工具，但人工智能仍然需要
花钱。 人工智能仍然需要进行交易。   你
猜怎么着？ 他们将使用
区块链技术。 嗯，他们会使用
更好的，呃，我们仍然需要一个好的，我们
仍然需要不断升级
当前的金融体系。 所以，嗯，
金融系统不会消失，就像
我们以前有区块链的时候一样，互联网也
没有消失。 人工智能、
区块链和互联网不会随着时代的发展而消失
。 嗯，这三项都是非常非常
大的技术。 呃，所以我觉得
很多人问我，你会不会
担心所有的钱都流向了
人工智能？ 不。呃，是有些钱花掉了，
但是没关系。 嗯，现在
钱很多，而且我们身处
金融行业。 即使是
流向那里的资金，现在仍然在
区块链上流动。   是的
。
正确的。 是的。
日益。 非常感谢币安
创始人赵长鹏（CZ）做客Galaxy
Brains节目。
哦，谢谢你们邀请我。 是的。
感谢您收听
Galaxy Research 出品的每周播客节目 Galaxy Brains。
我是 Galaxy 公司全公司研究主管 Alex Thorne
。 请在 X 上关注
Intangible Coins。 关注
Xgxy
Research 上的 Galaxy Research。 请访问 galaxy.com/ressearch 阅读我们的书面报告
。
如果您喜欢 Galaxy 品牌，请不要忘记
在您
最喜欢的播客平台（如 YouTube、
Spotify、Apple Podcasts 等）上点赞和订阅。 我们
下次再见。